they're approaching the cathedral and
presumably very different atmosphere it
was as quiet as you could hear a pin
drop someone told me when the Queen's
coffin made its way most definitely
um
you could hear everything when we
arrived at West Parliament Square you
the The Crying In The Crowd the best
wishes it was amazing you now see the
king
making his way out of the car heading in
for his service of Thanksgiving and
dedication Scotland's moment to Mark a
new monarch for a new reign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and Laura as the king and queen enter
the cathedral with other members of the
royal family
um it's fair to say I think as well as
the the cheers and the Applause uh quite
audible booing from the crowds there
well there were two protest pens
pre-arranged and one close to where I am
right outside the Palace of Hollywood
house the other as you heard right
outside the entrance to Saint Giles
Cathedral and speaking to one of the
organizers of the protest I think there
was certainly a sense that they wanted
to have their voices heard